if the FBI was a company
and they had a review online right now
and they had to fix their reputation man
I got a lot of work to do gain the trust
of the American people today I agree
100 but you have to understand and I'm
going to go back to a perfect example
just to put things in context as to why
the FBI is not the same FBI that's
recognizable not only to me but a lot of
people that are similarly situated that
have retired and still are there when I
got into the FBI there was a fit test
the fit test was you had to run a mile
and a half you had to do sit-ups you had
to do push-ups you had to do pull-ups do
you realize now that the FBI Academy has
done away with quote unquote the fit
test now again don't want to piss off
any of the people that are listening but
let's be honest
you have to be fit because the job
should be very physically
you know demanding in times and what
happened was there was a person who
couldn't pass the fit test they got
recycled once they got recycled twice
and then on the third time when they
couldn't pass the fit test they
terminated that person you know what
that person did probably sued them
that's exactly what happened they sued
and then you know what the FBI did they
said well it's a disability the person's
overweight
um maybe we don't need to have the fit
test so they disa they disa they did
away with the fit test exactly like I
say when you have the participation
trophies and now you have what year was
that by the way they did away with the
fit test in
2004 2000. so this has been coming for
death
no no no this has been coming the
softness correct and now we have how
does an FBI meet his criteria his CR his
his requirements yeah when I did that
that was the success of your cases
meaning you know you worked cases you
know if you ended up arresting someone
you got to that a boy now you have a
checklist how many informants how many
how much restitution how many seizures
how many warrants how many felony
convictions and so when you break it
down into a checklist
and you have a a chance to go either way
to arrest or not arrest someone well if
you realize you're coming up with your
performance appraisal and you need to
arrest someone you're going to arrest
that person why because you got to check
that box that's not the FBI that's
recognizable to me but when you make it
that way and by the way and what the
public doesn't understand and here's a
fact true scenario
if I come at a Podunk someplace in the
United States out of the academy and I
go to 26 Federal Plaza which is where
the FBI is located in New York City you
can imagine someone coming from little
place in Arkansas who now has to uproot
his family of four and try to find a
place to live within two hours of New
York City because you're not going to be
able to afford an apartment and now
you're going to work at 26 Federal Plaza
you can't find a legal parking spot and
you're absolutely miserable your kids
are miserable your wife is miserable
here's the reality after 18 months of
coming out of the Academy I can raise my
hand and take a specialty transfer to
FBI headquarters what does that do well
you'll spend the next 18 months at FBI
headquarters and then when you come out
of FBI headquarters you're now a
supervisor now think about this
you're in the bureau less than four
years and you're going to come out into
the field office and supervise guys that
have 15 20 25 years that's not going to
work but you have these young kids that
are doing this and now you have this
culture this mentality this social media
you know the you know you'll keep in
mind the kids that are coming out of the
academy are driven by social media by
the way when I went into the FBI you
couldn't have ever listen I'm 58 and I
can say this I have never smoked
marijuana and when I applied to the FBI
no drugs if you had done any drugs in
your life prior to applying to the FBI
it was automatic disqualification right
in this day and age it's now if you
haven't done marijuana in the last three
years now I'm not being critical I'm not
taking a position on marijuana but what
I'm saying is now we've we've changed
the rules we've changed we've lacked
some the applicant the type of
individual see
you know the the we I want the FBI to
have disciplined individuals and that's
why I'm the biggest advocate for people
that come out of the military why
because they are so disciplined and they
don't ask why they just do it and they
stand at attention they'll stand there
for 16 20 24 hours and they won't move
they won't go to the bathroom they won't
have to look at their cell phone you
know when I worked at the FBI no keep in
mind cell phones was something you
carried in a suitcase so not everybody
had a suitcase right we at best we had a
beeper we had a pager you go into the
FBI you know FBI agents they all have
cell phones everybody's on social media
everybody's getting their media there
their information through so through
social media that's making us brain dead
and I think there's a disconnect you
know the public thinks FBI FBI agents
are something above us being human no
the FBI is made up of human beings men
and women and the men and women that are
coming out of college coming out of
graduate school coming out into the
world have this demented distorted view
why because they're watching Tick Tock
their you know Facebook and all this
garbage that's being fed that's the new
and upcoming FBI agents we know the
military just recently is their lowest
ever recruiting shortage they've had and
a long time to the point where now
they're giving fifty thousand dollar
bonuses for six years uh just to join
it's like oh you're physical don't worry
about you're this so don't worry about
it it's a lot more don't worry don't
worry don't worry them before I have a
question I think you posted something
well the military is not as attractive
because now you can get your loan
forgiveness you know listen when when
people went to the military they went to
military because it deferred your
expense to going to college right why do
I have to do that why do I have to need
a six-year commitment to give back to
Uncle Sam and by the way I'm the biggest
advocate in proponent listen you want to
forgive forgiveness give though those
people that raise their hand and
volunteer and God forbid they have to go
over to unforsaken God awful countries
to protect you you and I yeah and when
they come back give them a house give
them health care for give them loan
forgiveness that's I'm good with that
but now you just want to give loan
forgiveness because I'm lazy and I don't
want to get off the couch and go get a
job I don't I don't agree with that so
there's where it's driving also the
military wow so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]